hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
microfluidics Without Borders
commercialization perspective of high
throughput applications for acoustic
droplet ejection technology presented by
dr. Sam irani senior director Rd
principal engineer lab site Inc I'm
julissa marathas labrys and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by leverage the
leading scientific social networking
websites and producer of educational
virtual agents and webinars before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time during the presentation just
click the green Q&A button located in
the lower left of the presentation
window and type your question into the
box that appears on the screen we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation for
questions not answered today we will
follow up with participants via email
also please notice that you will be
viewing the presentation in the slide
window to enlarge the window just click
on the icon located on the lower right
of the screen
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this is an educational webinar
and this offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the C e button
located in the bottom left-hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
of obtaining your credits please join me
in welcoming dr. Ronnie I will now turn
the presentation over to him
Thank You Julie for the very kind
introduction and I also thank the
organizers of lab woods for this
opportunity once again my name is Sammy
Donny I'm going to talk about micro
fluidics and specifically what we do at
lab site so I would take a second to
kind of honor someone who's been very
influential from a scientific
perspective and really the the point I
want to drive here is that science is
incremental and what I'm going to share
with you is definitely an incremental
improvement but it's got great
applications so to raise new questions
new possibilities to regard all problems
from a new angle requires creative
imagination it marks real advance in
science what we're doing in lab site is
essentially turning the world upside
down and I hope you get that message I
also thought I'd take a few seconds to
talk about micro fluidics and
nanotechnology this is focused on micro
fluidics and high-throughput automation
what is it and why do we care the Nobel
Prize winner Richard Feynman in 1959
gave a seminar lecture that is often
stated as a starting point for the
science of miniaturization and planted
the seeds for micro and nanotechnology
here's a great quote I really enjoy it
would be interesting if surgery in
surgery if you could swallow the surgeon
put the mechanical surgeon inside the
blood vessel and it goes into the heart
looks around and finds out which about
was faulty and one takes a little knife
and slices it out so that's the next
stage we're looking at organs on the
chip in the next generation of micro
fluidics but if you look on this slide
here on the left you have glass chips
that were made and these are part of
marco phobic chips there
sort of a closed platform you have a
caliper a sipper chip in the middle and
then you have another trip that was
basically enabled for doing
high-performance liquid chromatography
on a chip and the idea is that you use
nanotechnology and you can integrate
these components and these applications
on a chip and get exceptional
functionality now these are all very
closed systems if you would think of
analogy would be looking at Apple's
operating system and how its pretty
closed what we do at lab site is we have
a very open platform I'm going to talk
to you about that
so our open platform if you want to
think of it as very enabling it allows
users to do what they want the analogy I
have is kind of similar to what Google
is doing so a quick agenda I'm going to
talk to you about the lab side
technology what is a coup stick global
detection technology a little bit of
history how it works what can we measure
I'm going to talk about aqueous
capabilities remember the world is
primarily aqueous and so what are the
key components that we had to solve to
enable that dynamic measurements
managing meniscus tilt evaporation the
response to sample variability and the
range of materials we can acoustic and
transfer and I'm going to end with a
case study and that specifically shows
you some of the engines be we have
behind the technology next I'm going to
go into some applications these are
things that our customers use drug
discovery for screening compound
management we have applications in
protein crystallography estate
preparation to PCR and biochemical assay
assembly and then finally I'm going to
talk in depth about a gel
electrophoresis microarray this is
essentially a microfluidic platform that
leverages our our open platform and then
I'm going to end with the acoustic
loading of mass
ronger this is basically enabling sort
of a high-throughput mass spectrometry
directly from a micro played well and
I'll end with some conclusions and take
questions
Saku speck droplet ejection technology
out of this is not new this is kind of
goes back to that very first slide we're
taking an example of something that was
done historically early 20s people were
focusing basically not at the fluid
surface and you take a piezoelectric
transducer like you see in this
technical disclosure at the bottom and
by not focusing in the fluid surface you
had uncontrolled drop size so you have
this piezoelectric transducer which
you're not focusing at the fluid surface
and the early 70s groups at IBM started
focusing in the fluid surface and you
were able to control drop size and
trajectory so that enables things like
document printing applications and folks
at recognition equipment and Xerox
pounded a few of these ideas all the
rage now something called 3d printing
but it really stemmed out of
microstereolithography this is a
basically parts manufacturer and this
was done in the early 90s lab side was
founded in the year 2000 and we started
with acoustic droplet ejection for life
science applications in the year 2010 we
expanded to a grid capabilities
so we move liquid sound we are
physically turning the world upside down
we transfer from a micro well plate into
an inverted destination plate and
because of surface tension small drops
have the tendency to stick to surfaces
so we transfer there's no physical
contact we have perfect sample integrity
we have low energy transfer we make very
consistent drop sizes there are the two
nanometers or 25-man leaders and were
able to push out about 200 to 500
droplets per second we transfer to an
inverted plate and because of surface
tension and electrostatics we're able to
hold drops upside down and this is
touchless and it eliminates nozzles tips
and improves reliability precision
eliminates washing and eliminates the
need for pipette tips and eliminates the
potential for cross-contamination we use
the technology called dynamic fluid
analysis and essentially we have a lot
of signal processing in the background
we're able to automatically adapt to
your sort of properties and adjust in
real time so we're able to handle a
variety of fluids so life Said's various
reagents concentrations glycerol storage
solutions DNA RNA
there's no operator intervention and
this miniaturizes processes that were
previously not feasible so we're talking
about a two and a half nan liters drop
which is about 116 microns in diameter
and that's our discretization could you
please play the video echo animation
found energy to move ultra low volume
droplets of liquid from a source
location to an inverted destination with
extremely high precision and accuracy
ecosystems move droplets of 2.5 nano
liters per ejection to transfer larger
volumes of liquid multiple droplets are
ejected from the source at up to 500
times per second the lab site echo 500
series liquid handlers use a de to
transfer liquids from 384 or 1536 well
micro plates into 96 384 1536 and 3456
well destination plates appropriate for
your experimental needs the echo system
presents a source fleet gripper and
robotically or manually a fill source
plate is placed upon the extended
platform the extended gripper pulls the
plate into the echo system where it is
deionized to ensure straight flight of
the droplets the destination gripper is
extended and inverted to hold a
destination plate the destination plate
is flipped and pulled into the echo
system surface tension will keep fluids
in the wells of an inverted destination
place slowing water
couples the transducer to the source
plate the transducer is positioned in
Mesa well and emits a soft piing of
energy energy is reflected from each of
the three interfaces the bottom of the
plate the bottom of the well and the
meniscus of the fluid in the well the
echo system uses the amplitude of the
reflected sound to calculate the level
of hydration of DMSO if this solvent is
used in the source and the delay of the
final reflection to calculate the depth
of the fluid in the well a well filled
to a greater depth requires a longer
time for the reflection to return from
the surface the fluid in each well is
analyzed as shown here in slow motion
the information provided by the survey
determines that the proper eject
and parameters and transducer
positioning are used to ensure accurate
and precise nano leader transfers the
actual total analysis time for a
384-well plate is less than 26 seconds
once the wells have been surveyed the
transducer returns to the first well
focuses the acoustic energy where the
survey determines the meniscus to be and
emits a stronger ping of energy the
energy causes a 2.5 nano litre droplet
to eject from the surface and to slide
up into the appropriate well of the
destination plate above it surface
tension captures and holds the droplet
in the well fluid from the same source
well can be ejected into another well of
the destination plate more droplets are
ejected to increase the volume echo
systems can transfer to dry or pre
filled destination wells
a record of empty source wells is kept
to help eliminate false negatives
ecosystems can transfer five nanoliters
from each well of a 384-well plate to a
corresponding destination plate in less
than 37 seconds cycle time can be less
than 95 seconds when the transfer is
complete the destination plate is
extended and inverted to allow another
plate to enter the system ecosystems can
up stack or down stack two plates of
higher or lower density source plates
are easily changed to move from low
density plates into high density formats
the ecosystems use precise and accurate
ad technology to transfer nano leader
volumes of fluids with no tips or
nozzles saving you hundreds of thousands
of dollars annually eliminating surfaces
that can touch the transferred fluids
also prevents cross-contamination and
losses to surface absorption to ensure
more sensitive and accurate detection of
your best hits the echo 500 series
liquid handlers are the choice for ultra
low volume liquid transfers great I'm
going to jump to the next slide so we
basically use sonar Doppler medical
ultrasound to do this analysis in the
background and the user doesn't have to
take care of that we have a variety of
instruments that have this capability to
send dynamic fluid analysis they are
ready out of the box there contact free
in terms of transfer this eliminates tip
costs you can go from any wells any well
you can do cherry picking applications
direct dilution ringing applications
plate replication and you can integrate
with a third party in terms of
automation
so here is a little hill slide and I
meant a little bit about our access lab
laboratory workstation it's a bench top
automation solution for the echo liquid
handler it is targeted it has modular
solutions and there's a range of device
accessories and configurations available
they are designed to scale from so assay
development to full screening practices
configuration and options are factory
tested for target applications this
comes fully optimized out-of-the-box
they are very quick to integrate usually
a customer's able to run the system on
the first day you can add new devices
and you can reconfigure on demand we've
also developed our own software platform
and that's called tempo which
incorporates the echo software
applications and you don't have to make
custom scripts or programs and you can
export this information into limbs and
other databases we have to get into the
consumables business out because we need
to hear through the plastic we need to
understand how the acoustic energy goes
through in order to keep our extreme
high precision and acts accuracy of our
performance so we've gotten into the
micro plate business we make plates out
of three four out of propylene or CLC
materials and we also make plates in 384
or 1536 style these are all SPS or SLA a
standard plates and we even have some
microcline lids and they're enabling
different capabilities to prevent
evaporation or hydrations you're talking
about materials in the wells
in terms of our technology we've
basically been growing by expanding the
fluid range what we have or plots on the
x-axis is the discuss 'ti and on the
y-axis is the surface tension and as you
move from version one to version two to
version three you can see that we're
starting to encompass more of this
because the space bases 2d phase space
and currently we are in this third
version where we're basically looking at
being able to transfer the whole range
of surface tension and the whole range
of viscosity one of the artifacts we
noticed was protein meniscus influences
the behavior in micro plates so you've
got proteins that are sticky and they
tend to tear to the walls typically
someone running a protein and in a micro
well plate will centrifuge it and they
end up having a tilt since we use our
transducer to both send and receive
signal as such if the surface is flat
you get the signal it returns if the
surface is tilted signal doesn't come
back so this is a problem we had to
solve and it's result it's resolved with
some IP that we developed so we had to
invent a way to basically create
creative solutions the meniscus shape
also changes depending on what's in the
micro well so we have four different
solutions here you have buffer on the
Left buffer with protein next to that
that shows you a slightly tilted
meniscus you have a
concentration of surfactant that gives
you a shallow curved meniscus you see if
I could highlight that here and the same
thing if you have a higher concentration
you see a steeper meniscus what we're
able to do with our technology is
basically we're able to take a map to
the map of that interface to determine
how filtered it is and we use that
information when it comes to
transferring reproducibly and precisely
here's another example of how what's
inside the micro well has impact so if
you apply the same amount of power but
you have three different little G of
ethanol on the Left water on the right
and the mobility of intermediate surface
tension to Triton x100 you can see that
if you apply the same amount of power
the ethanol drop detaches early and it
also brings with it a potential daughter
drop or even a third drop with the same
amount of power if you apply that to an
intermediate concentration of tried next
100 you get one drop and almost a second
drop go if you have the right amount of
power you just get one drop in the mound
retracts so being able to adapt on the
fly is one of the capabilities that has
allowed us to use our technology and the
variety of other applications which I'll
discuss so what do we get we get really
consistent quality across the variety of
food classics shown here is the transfer
volume so you have both the volume
accuracy and volume precision for
transferring and over a variety of
fluids so we're looking at 0 to 60
percent glycerol 70 to 100 percent DMS 0
0 to 100 percent fetal calf serum and 25
to 200 percent of the CMC of try
x100 so we're trying to transfer 59
litres so these are 20 drops that are
being transferred from our source plate
into a destination plate our source
plate is doped with a solution of sodium
fluorescein and then that's transferred
to a destination plate that's upside
down to transfer 20 drops and then you
poke so with some sodium hydroxide and
you quickly run an assay and you compare
the fluorescence to that that you would
obtain from a standard curve and here
are the results basically you have very
precise volume accuracy and an excellent
drawing precision so since we were
talking about micro fluidics
I wanted to highlight that this is a
very open platform and we are doing
micro fluidics we're just not inside the
channel and I wanted to talk a little
bit about that so the drop really
doesn't care it can go out of a micro
plate as you can see here on the left
into a regular device so you could use
it for a loading application you could
also use it for an unloading application
from a microfluidic device into a micro
well plate or you could go from micro
silica device into an analytical
instrument and think about this this
application on the right a little bit
this is similar to what we're going to
be doing we're the ku Stickley loading
and mass spectrometers
we can precisely have control over the
direction in volume and you can see we
have stroboscopic image of a drop going
through the eye of a needle and into a
capillary so we can easily unload or
load microcytic devices that shouldn't
be a challenge here we have droplet
ejection into the capillary there are a
lot of capillary based systems that can
be used with within microfluidic
workflows so you could be loading your
CD that's capillary base you can be
loading around see that capillary based
and you can be using acoustics to get
your sample in so what's the range of
materials and what can we transfer I
mentioned this earlier hundred percent
to 70 percent in DMSO we can also do 0
to 30% EMS or aqueous solutions water
salt solutions buffers surfactant
solutions I talked about Triton x100
we can transfer an ionic surfactants
like sodium dodecyl sulphate DNA primers
probes we have some customers that use
the make si RNA libraries with our
technology we can transfer proteins BSA
let's design fetal calf serum all the
way to 100 percent glycerol has been
transferred to 60% alcohols plasma we
didn't transfer blood and put into some
kits we are also starting to look at
some of the polymeric solutions
acrylamide and some others and also some
ionic liquids so I want to talk to you a
little bit about how we do what we do
and that has to do essentially with the
signal processing in the background and
if we turn this DFA feature this dynamic
fluid analysis feature of our on versus
off so I'll describe the experiment to
you the case study is basically looking
at the feature the software feature
turned on or off and here we have a
prototype reservoir play shown here on
the left
and what we've done is we've put the
micro plate which is a reservoir it's a
six world reservoir we put it into our
ecosystem we've taken the skins off and
the reservoir enables you to hold
roughly two point eight milliliters of
your sample and we're able to transfer
this instrument transfers 25 nano liters
at a time so it's discretizing 28 or
sorry 2.8 milliliters in 25 nanometer
increments and we're going to actually
put a camera in here and see how that
process is so we put a side view droplet
imaging camera within our instrument and
you can see that highlighted by the
circle on the left here is our capturing
scheme so we basically have a camera and
we have a stroke going and you're going
to see the same droplet in three
different positions and here's our
triggering scheme we basically have a
delay and then we start our exposure and
we have three three strokes and then we
repeat this so you're going to see some
videos and the videos are going to show
you the same drop in three different
positions I want you to think about if
you've captured this the physics then
you want the droplet velocity to be the
same which means the space between the
drops shouldn't change so let's jump to
those videos could you can you play the
first video MIP off window one please
you
so I think the method she wanted from
that video was the space between the
drops so it's the same drop in three
different positions and the space
between that was changing over time and
with this dynamic fluid analysis feature
turned off essentially you have a
situation where there are some stray
drops you may have noticed that and the
actual velocity is changing of the time
so the next video shows you the end of
this transfer process so remember your
discretizing 2.8 milliliters and 25
nanometer increments so it takes a few
minutes so we're just jumping to the
video at the end of the process
could you play the second video in my
pee off window too please
you
I really like that video it basically
shows that with this feature turned off
you have a very chaotic process the
drops are bouncing off each other
they're not getting to the destination
and so this tells me that we don't have
something that's sellable the third case
essentially is we're going to redo this
experiment and we're going to turn this
then include analysis feature on so this
is all the signal processing in the
background and what I want to convince
you is that the distance between the
drops stays the same so you see the same
drop in three different positions and
over the time course what you will see
is that that space between the drop
stays the same and that tells you that
the velocity is the same could you
please play the third video 6 kV grid on
please
you
great so I think that take-home is that
the drops the distance between those
drops stayed the same the same drop in
three different positions so that also
highlights that we have a very dialed in
process we're also moving the
destination because eventually if you
have too much fluid that you're
transferring upside down it will fall
back down next thing I want to talk to
you about is some of the applications so
with this capability we're able to do a
variety of applications we're going to
start first with the rain we actually
buy a lot of this water sensitive paper
if you take source well and you saw it
with different surface tension different
fluids with different surface tension
you don't even know what they are
basically you can transfer in this case
we're transferring 100 nano leaders so
four drops with that large large drop
instrument that transfers 25 nanometers
per time and you see that there no
satellites and the point I want to drive
home is that this you have a very well
dialing process you don't have satellite
applications and drug discovery our Echo
trees for performance is actually
independent of transfer volume this was
published in a drug discovery by John
Connelly looking at Manly they're
dispensing it really highlights so use
that volume on the bottom and you've got
the variation in the volume on the on
the y axis and if you look at a variety
of technologies as you drive from larger
volume down to lower volume you see that
most of the technologies start to have
more and more variation especially when
you get down to sort of 10 nanometers
and below except for the lab side echo
there are problems of the traditional
liquid handling here's a really good
example where
our partners AstraZeneca basically
discovered a class of cancer
therapeutics using the echo of liquid
handler these therapeutics would have
been missed using the general generic
pecan genesis which is essentially a
pipette base liquid handler and what
i've actually highlighted here is the
results of a nice e15 curve where you've
looked at the ratio that's generated by
the lab side echo versus the t10 genesis
so if the two technologies are doing the
same thing that they should be one but
it turns out that depending on the
compound ratio changes there is
something else going on and we believe
that these are some of the problems that
get addressed by using acoustic
dispensing applications in protein
crystallography we had a customer that
was interested in transferring fluids
from actual protein crystallography kit
these were essentially the kind of kits
like one example is the hampton set and
essentially transferred from a source
plate of 30 microliters and we used a
384 ploy clean plate we had a
specification set at 94 of 98 different
fluids so we don't know what these
fluids are we just put them in our micro
plate or use decker instrumented
transfer them the way we did this is we
set up a surrogate fluid and this is
glycerol and we looked at zero to sixty
percent glyceryl concentrations in water
and we did a factory acceptance test to
determine the accuracy and precision and
the results are shown here so very good
accuracy and precision the follow along
is to actually take our technology and
these protein crystal formation and
these were were results from Paris from
Genentech where he went and did
the echo dispense of both the protein
solution and then the protein
crystallography reagents and we did this
at 25 nanometers and you can see on the
right that you have these protein
crystal clusters being formed and they
are formed in these sort of target wells
that have three shells in one reservoir
we have another customer this one is
from Gilead that did some more protein
crystals formation at the nanometer
scale I like this because it's just a
beautiful image and it shows you
essentially these protein crystals that
are formed at the nanometer scale using
our technology so they show you the same
results when you look at the x-ray
diffraction in terms of assay
preparation and miniaturization we've
done a variety of work sort of driving
to lower volumes we took a variety of
cell and biochemical assay kits so four
kits with 11 reagents and then we use
them to transfer and look at essentially
the the coefficient variation of the
droplet transfer so we didn't even know
what these kits were we didn't know what
the regions were inside the kits and the
one thing I want to highlight is in the
blue circle that shows you that the
transfers TVs so that is one point three
percent 0.95% if you are looking at two
drops transfer or twenty drops
transferred the next thing to do was to
look at a antibody screening with the
homogeneous time-resolved fluorescence
assay and essentially this is a human
assist bio screening assay where we
looked at titrating the human antibody
from point one to twenty five nanograms
per well in twofold Aleutians we
transferred with the instrument the 110
nine meters
European Cup date which is the donor and
then we also transfer the acceptor at
100 nanometers and then we added 40
microliters of the buffer the assay was
run and you can see the the scheme on
the right essentially we had excellent
at the results our D prime was point
eight three for qpcr we also looked at
can our instrument be instrumental in
sort of driving down volume and can it
be used for making some of these assays
first of all we looked at cross
contamination so we put this is for 1536
Q PCR test we put D positives in the
top-left of the quadrant wanting the
positives in quadrant two was in the top
right the positive in quadrant three was
on the bottom left and positive in the
quadrant four was on the bottom right so
essentially we transferred cDNA to the
positive world and then all the other
primers probes master mix went to all
the wells and then we looked at the
amplification curves and saw what the
results were so here we're doing a QV
cof a this is a 509 later off a cDNA is
500 picograms per reaction what I want
to sort of highlight is that every well
that's supposed to be green is green and
those are the positives and every well
that supposed to be red it's supposed to
be random so we didn't see any
cross-contamination we're also able to
use the roche cell lysis of the one-step
lysis and look at a cell titration so we
looked at cell densities from 500 to
10,000 cells per well this was a one
microliter in total reaction volume and
we looked at the crossing point which is
going to change as a function of the
solvent to me because there's different
amounts of DNA the point I want to drug
home is the low coefficient of variation
again so on the order of 1%
we can also use our technology to
actually do dilution so we can dilute
cDNA within our instrument to basically
avoid having to do our hand pipetted
steps and so what we did here is we took
the DNA to run a PCR experiment and did
twofold Aleutians from twenty five
nanograms all the way down to one point
five six Democrats and you can see on
the right here the actual heat map so
some of the highlights there is no
detectable cross-contamination
it's very reproducible we generate
real-time data low standard deviations
those TVs assay can be miniaturized it's
very flexible with our technology it's
one well that can go from any well to
any well it's rapid and very accurate so
you can set up a plate in order of 12
minutes for 1536 okay applications I
want to dive into a gel electrophoresis
microarray microarray application
essentially can we use our technology
for determining and having a high
location accuracy or protein solution
that's transformed gel so remember we
have protein solution being transformed
and gel and so you really are fighting
diffusion so the desired features
essentially our location accuracy we
want to sort of hit the bull's eye every
time there are three three examples were
fully filled if we're hitting the bull's
eye Porsche a solder for a little bit
off and you could be fully offset so we
looked at that we looked at the volume
uniformity and this can be determined
visually and electro phoretic ly and
then speed and how long does it take to
perform a full three to four gel or play
transfer this work was published in
Nature scientific reports late last year
so here are the results essentially we
have quantitative performance sample
delivery using an acoustic acoustic
droplet injection
essentially we get fully filled with a
de comparing to pin tools where most of
the time your your partially filled and
we actually didn't even bother with the
manual pipette in terms of volume
uniformity the CD and band intensity is
on the order of a percent and you can
determine that it's not as good with the
pin tools and the manual pipette we did
run this and it was about 29% in terms
of speed this sort of relates to being
able to do a high throughput application
it took the acoustic droplet ejection
technology about three minutes pin tools
took about 15 minutes and then annual
podcast about 20 minutes so once again
I'm talking about transferring proteins
or antibodies to a gel and essentially
there's going to be diffusion so the
faster you do that process to more
accurately and precisely your sample
bands will be when you run the
electrophoresis so if you look at the
transfers on the Left you have to a de
loading which takes about three minutes
and on the right you have the manual
loading are blown up three wells just
below that and those three wells show
you essentially the bands that were
separated when a potential difference
was applied and then you can calculate
peak intensities so we determined that
using a de is 8% and using manual
loading it's 29% then we went and worked
with some researchers at UCSF they have
these recombinant antibodies for the
recombinant antibody network and we were
looking at basically looking at electro
phoretic mobility shift assay on this
general polyacrylamide gel and we wanted
to use this technology for their free
image and binding to
the dissociation constants so we looked
at a concentration gradient we looked at
a variety of different combatant
antibodies and we determined the
dissociation constants so this also
compared favorably with the octet bli
which is the standard that's used in the
industry so let's look at the results
the advantage of using a de with this
gel over other tools essentially you get
more with less if you look at 18 with
this gel it's about 400 data points per
hour the manual loading gets you a
little under 100 data points per hour
and octet bli you'll get one data point
per hour that translates directly to the
dissociation constant throughput per
hour so the key is you are using much
less sample three times ten to the minus
eight grams with a de which is 1 times
10 to the minus 5 grams with the octet
bli or 1 times 10 to the minus 5 with
analyzer so you're using much less
sample consumption both antibody and
ligand and we think that there's a great
capability to make this a
high-throughput application the next
application I'm going to talk about is
high to good mass spectrometry and we're
using our acoustic technology for that
so why use mass spectrometer screen
typically people use readers in inner
fluorescence base meter what we'll have
to add a fluorescence marker so mass
spectrometry for screening is great
because this could be labeled free it
reduces the risk of artifact it's lower
cost
no complex as a reagent approaches you
can also do rapid assay development you
can imagine being able to screen the
same while many times over and you're
able to get sample kinetics you are
allowed to look at a wide range of
endpoints could be proteins lipids DNA
you get a too high content readout so
you can look at pathway analysis tableau
mix and then sensitivities on the order
of sentiment a Kimura so why hasn't this
happened so this is a slide I'm entitled
towards label-free HTS of mass spec
despite the progress speed remains the
bottleneck so we're going to look at
different techniques and the time per
sample and the time to do 1 million
samples and I have a comment associated
of TMS is the gold standard it takes 1
to 15 minutes per sample depending on if
you run in gradient separations it will
take you two years to run through 1
million samples so it's expensive you
can multiplex to show the screening
screening time that you do have solvent
and sample consumptions that are
different in 2010 the rapid fire was
introduced and this takes about 10
seconds per sample it would take you
then for 1 million samples about 110
days so this uses solid phase extraction
and the main application is really in
post
HTS Multi multi has some matrix issues
for small molecules and they are complex
workflows and you're looking at putting
your sample onto a substrate it takes
one to ten one to five seconds per
sample and then for a million samples it
will take you on the order of 12 days
what we're calling with our acoustic
version of the echo we call that the
echo MS it takes you point three seconds
per sample and you'll be able to do 1
million compound screen about 3.5 days
so you can eject an ionized directly
from the plate and we use only
nanoliters example we've been very
fortunate to work with two partners
basically Waters provides the mass
spectrometer and AstraZeneca and last
sight together we're developing this
acoustic mass spec platform and trying
to put it to good use
so what's the difference so this is a
method that it's similar to electrospray
ionisation but it's actually a little
bit different with electrospray
ionisation you essentially have a sheet
gas at high pressure and you have a
capillary and you are creating you
basically working in electric field and
you have a tail of cone and then
droplets are sort of dispersed from the
tip of that Taylor cone these droplets
are charged in the electric field and
then make its way into the mass
spectrometer there be solvated and ions
turn into signal with the acoustic mass
spec source we basically are ejecting
directly from a micro well plate we have
basically a ultrasonic fluid ejection
cone we dispense
drops that then become charged in the
electric field and these are on the
order of 1 to 20 microns so here are the
features between ESI and echo ms key
ones to point out our sort of sample
flow is on the order of 1 to 100
microliters per minute and for the ESI
and for echo MS it's 5 micro liters per
minute droplet size I mentioned with ESI
it's on the order of less than 5 microns
the echo ms is on the order of 1 to 20
microns similar electric fields similar
Inlet temperatures and similar
sensitivity and I'm going to talk to you
about that so we use our technology to
both deliver and then we ionize samples
directly from micro plates and here is a
schematic at the top view you see on the
right here or micro plate underneath the
micro plate is our piezoelectric
transducer and we dispense drops
directly into a transfer line
so we have our transistor assembly we
have our micro plate we have the
collection nozzle which applies the
electric field we have a heated transfer
interface and then we have the mass back
on the well so we're working with the
front end and these are waters sqd 2t q
XS or the g2 that's here is the echo and
s alpha breadboard so we have a few of
these installed globally so we have four
units in total two I are installed and
used for real high throughput screening
assays we have basically a picture you
can see the nozzle transfer interface
the mass spec front end microplate in
the transducer assembly we had to come
up with clever way to make sure our
microplates don't build up charge and
we're actually patented with that and
some of this work is described in the
journal of lab automation by Sinclair
angle at all here is a photo essentially
of the acoustic mist that's created on
the right and on the left is the analogy
I talked mostly about dispensing
droplets that are on over to NASA now
leaders let's take a look at that so on
the left you have this video where you
see one droplet coming out and on the
right you have this burst of this
acoustic mist and that's what is
transferring to our interface next thing
we do we can sample basically three
samples per second so we have states
that moves and so we can process 384
well plate quite quickly
we have also enabled automations so we
have fast click swapping using our
robotic integration so this allows you
to have over eight hours of walk away
operation here we're looking at some
data acquisitions so this is the
extracted iron time trace of an isolated
tripeptide substrate at 601
mass-to-charge we are looking at the
data from 60 samples processed in 18
seconds I'm going to talk about this a
little bit later so what you end up with
is essentially how do you curate this
data because you're generating so much
data so we have the lab site I can ask
back and then we have the waters mass
spectrometer they are connected to the
mass links PC the information is then
sent to gene data for screening and then
the individual Wells and our bend so you
have the ions that are Bend and they're
they're basically then processed into
individual well mass spectrum so you
need to come up with a different
methodology and we have this echo and
mass link software that handles and
curates data in a timely fashion next
thing I'm going to talk to you about
some preliminary performance I've shown
you how we go from ejection to getting
data first I'd like to convince you that
we have an apples to apples comparison
with the waters ESI source that shows
you that the sensitivity in the
detection is very similar
so we looked at the echo LMS versus the
electrospray interface performance on
the same waters single clog fq d 2 we
looked at the linear range de limit of
detection building the quantitation and
we looked at two simple analytes glue
tube which is 786 mass-to-charge in the
positive mode and we looked at warfarin
and that's 309 Massa charge in the
positive mode so here is a graph that
shows you the corrected signal versus
the concentration so we made a variety
of serial dilutions and then transferred
this using the echo and map platform and
then also compare that to the air to the
interfacing with water single quad and
as you can see that the linearity is is
very similar and you can see that the
range is also very similar I'm going to
look at the data and mover more so we're
able to use 39 years of molecular mass
versus 5 thousand nanometers using
standard ESI what I want to highlight is
the similar limit of detection and limit
of quantitation between the echo Ms for
D 2 analytes Gusev in warfarin and we
actually have a little less background
signal the next thing we did was use the
echo Ms for a high-throughput compound
screen we looked we basically have two
echo and as breadboards one one an
orderly part in the UK any other in
github part in USA they are both paired
with the waters cute off mass
spectrometers and they're used for a
high-throughput compound screening was
completed at 300,000 compound screen for
beautify on thyself a is read up days
and we have another screen in progress
I'm going to focus on the first screen
so this is the giveth ion disulfide
disulfide reductase the GS RFA it's the
first screen and we looked at
basically comparing how we perform so we
did an HTS 200 thousand compounds and we
look for inhibitory or agonist behavior
so essentially you have this dimer that
under some enzyme activity converts to a
monomer so the beautify on the gsh is
also used by cells to prevent oxidative
stress and we generate antioxidants it
eliminates foreign chemical agents and
it can reduce peroxide to wire so as
implications in cancer research so the
gsh oxidizes to go defiant disulfide
this is the GSS G and then GSR reduces g
SS G back to G SH maintaining the supply
so our output we are doing a ratio
metric measurement we're doing a ratio
of the 611 this is the substrate GSS g2
the product GS h which is at 306
mass-to-charge one thing we have to do
because we're not using liquid
chromatography step we have to actually
engineer the buffers and this is a work
that we've done in concert with
AstraZeneca so our workflow is we take
20 microliters of enzyme plus the
compound from the screen your incubate
for 10 minutes you add 20 microliters of
gsst and then you iq8 for 60 minutes and
you quench the reaction and then you can
read this by transferring it from the
echo mass back results for determining
the conversion we end up using the
enzyme that one can buy on the shelf and
these were the conditions we basically
have pH buffer to twist at 7.4 50
micromolar or triton x-100
one of the other things you can do with
this technology is you can determine
asset parameters in real time if you
wanted to determine the km for an
enzymatic reaction you could determine
that in real time this would take on the
order of 30 minutes if you were to use
standard C you might Spade might be
spending on order of 20 hours so you
have raw signal and conversion as a
function of time and you can do this
optimization to determine your V Max and
your km for your reaction over here we
have data from the actual screen itself
so you've basically been able to screen
pure 84 compounds on the order of 3
minutes you actually have the iron trace
here this is the time trace for the
substrate at 611 that's the charge the
product at 306 mastercharge and then
this min which is essentially the tells
you about the inhibitor so if you take a
blow-up of the graph on the left and
look at just nine samples and you can
see the inactive them in the max and
inhibitor the min compound essentially
tells you if there's an inhibitor and in
this case you can see that the
mass-to-charge shows you that it is
present and so you have an internal
standard you look at substrate to
product ratios and that tells you
information about your actual your
actual analysis and whether there is an
inhibitor or not you take this data and
you put it into gene data screener and
then you can do a whole plate analysis
and we actually ran through 240,000
samples that were processed in 666 hours
we ran a concordance test with our CMS
so our technology was able to do this in
four point four minutes echo ms
technology would take you about 20 hours
so a small sample was done not the whole
the result is over 95% cost savings for
AstraZeneca for 300,000
on screen you're only doing that for
about 15,000 dollars so there's massive
cost savings compared to a label screen
there's $50,000 saved their agents alone
there's a significantly faster than
other label free options there's a lower
false positive rate there's less than
100 high-quality hits generated and
there's a real risk of wasting time and
money
further down the pipeline The Economist
also measures protein so you can see a
charged protein envelope for ubiquitin
over here so just a mask and that shows
you the different chart states so with
this i go ms platform we can directly
acoustically ionize and you can get
subsample sub-second sample processing
and this enables a high throughput
screening so our echo lagoon handler is
customized with an external stage for in
3 384 well plates and a new transfer
line to carry ion to the mass spec
modified assays can be run without LC
cleanup and that enables real-time assay
development and that's label-free
300,000 compounds are screen and results
were inconclusive HPLC ms and progress
towards a commercial instrument we've
shown you robotic automation software to
masslynx
which shows you the echo and the mass
spectrometer world sampling so we have a
big data management for curating the
data in a timely manner we do that via
gene data screener we are looking to
expand applications and further
commercialize so quickly I'm going to
give you some conclusions we have this
built-in intelligence that allows
excellent accuracy and precision for a
variety of fluids with real-time
analysis this is the dynamic fluid
analysis I mentioned earlier it allows
you to have real-time monitoring
capability for fluids like DNS so that
I'd rate this role others its robust
when you start its robust throughout the
process and the system adapts to
changing conditions prevents
cross-contamination there are no tips
there are a variety of applications drug
discovery process monitoring
qpcr protein crystallography biochemical
assay assembly gel electrophoresis mass
spectrometry and many more and we're
investigating commercialization of new
applications for height support
experimentation with that I would like
to acknowledge a variety of
collaborators some from UC Berkeley
professor Amy hares lab you Chen pan
from UCSF Carolina woods niak and
Michael Hornsby from AstraZeneca Hmong
Baughman dr. Winfield in Sinclair from
waters corporation's T Pringle is Jones
and then from website variety folks on
my team
Eric sack man recall with Ghislaine
which Olsen Richard Stearns
Lars Nahas Siletz Glaser Maria Santana
in Schreiber swari
and a variety of others with that I'd
like to thank you for your attention and
open up the floor for some questions
Thank You dr. Gulani for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the green to an eight button at the
lower left of the presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on your screen and click on the
send button well answer as many of your
questions as we have time for if we are
unable to get to your questions
we will follow up via email after the
presentation let's get started the first
question is can you change the size of
the droplet right now the transducer
that okay the quick answer is the
transducer that you have
has a certain bandwidth and frequency
and that sets the size of the droplet so
you you can change the amount that you
transfer by transferring two drops four
drops twenty drops whatever you want but
you can actually change the size of the
droplet on the fly you'd have to use a
different transducer the next question
is can you use any vendor microplate so
we've had to get into the business of
micro plates because we want to ensure
the quality and the reproducibility and
accuracy of the transfer we're not sure
if somebody were to make a plate whether
we'd have the same sound that goes
through that so we've taken that sort of
on us to make sure that in order for us
to enable the high quality high
precision and high accuracy we make the
plate most likely we can transfer from
any plate but fundamentally you're not
going to get that extreme level of
quality next question is how do you have
such precise control of the droplet
transfer so we make one drop at a time
and this technology has been around for
a long time we use a piezoelectric
crystal that's embedded in the
transducer we use a sound signal that we
have absolute control of and so we're
able to do one drop very accurately and
very precisely and we repeat that same
process
over and over and we'll wrap up with one
last question
and that question is how many drops can
you transfer so with the current
electronics we can typically go on the
order of two to five hundred drops per
second so if you take a 25 nano liter or
if you looked at a two and a half nine
liter that works out to be over one
micro liter per second the 25 nano meter
you start to get higher flow rate but
basically we are looking at ways to go
faster and not compromise on on the
signal fidelity and drop quality
typically 500 is is a limit I would like
to once again thank dr. Gulani for his
presentation I would also like to thank
lab roots for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through August 25th 2017 you will
receive an email from lab roots letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who's
made this today's live student that's
all for now thank you for joining us we
hope to see you again soon goodbye